hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to a late-night drink
one of the best damn knees who custom
stories I've ever played in my entire
life okay let's go into joy I have a
funny feeling that things are gonna
start turning a bit darker soon Oh what
is that much oh oh oh okay
hmm a little early but I think I'll have
a drink oh you alcoholic you why not
just crack open a 12-pack of wine and
throw down a couple of beer coolers and
you'll be good to go maybe a little
drinky drink okay
I'm gonna keep an eye out for very
obscurely hidden keys cuz I know there's
bound to be a lot oh god damn it there's
one in this room oh you son of a [ __ ] I
just looked everywhere
cuz conspicuity I'm home oh welcome back
I didn't think you'd be home this early
well I wasn't feeling so right where oh
you should have called me I would have
come out I can take care of myself you
don't need to convince me yeah let me
just take my drink let me pour you a
drink
that wouldn't be a good idea still not
feeling very well
no I'm prayers with a baby baby oh my
god whose is it the doctor said you
couldn't he said my chances were really
low here let me oh you're in the room
wait a minute no I'll do it you get some
rest
I'm not that far along [ __ ] I don't
care you're not lifting a finger for
nine months huh I'm gonna get so fat oh
wait is this okay oh wait a minute oh oh
okay well that was all there was to Joy
that little thing with the baby baby
okay congratulations on the kid I mean I
don't know how old that memory is but
congrats nonetheless dot dot dot dot
thank you hi alone yes the key that's
the key word the most awful word in the
English tongue murder doesn't hold a
candle do it and hell is only a poor
synonym I don't know if you can see this
but it's
mime grunt oh it's the mime gun oh happy
with it I can't wait
I think I'm doing rather well all things
considered don't get cocky I've opened
the fear door you have a water phobia
right well I don't I don't so I should
be fine that makes sense
let's hope you're right okay sorrow and
fear yep I knew is about to get this way
let's go right into it if this game can
make me laugh and really love it I know
it can scare me pretty good Oh red well
then let's see what you have in store
wait what then oh okay me I should hide
in the closet oh hi why was the flying
naked guy the grunt came in and flew off
all my clothes oh well isn't this a
familiar situation I wonder what's gonna
happen can I take a peek no I can't even
take a peek his closets rather illogical
II placed already gonna do you're just
gonna go away okay
okay Oh what up what where did I go
where did I go that doesn't make any
sense what's that oh this is cracking
floor wait a minute ah well then that
was really well done by the way okay
whoa whoa there Nelly I think I would
have been fine but still wait a minute
what though oh okay I thought I was it
entering water I'm just entering gat
noxious gas all right okay let's do it
water monsters eh I can take it unless
you're gonna throw something else at me
eeny meeny miny moe catch a Moo hey I'm
surprised that Michael doesn't have
anything to say about this unusual
circumstance it's just a dank sewer with
a lot of mushrooms anything else what
okay thought I saw something
mind I don't even know what I'm looking
for him oh hello what's this Oh looky
goodies picked up oil Sandy potion sandy
potion loud down a dumb thing else huh
hose a point of this guess there's a
special bonus if I came down this way
if you got something good you better
show it soon I'm ready for you this ah
what is this stuff Oh
Oh okay run yes Oh
all the undulating flesh much worse than
undulating trees in my opinion yeah it's
everywhere so uh
something gonna happen okay never mind
sorry I spoke oh hello miss your water
monster what are you doing in these
parts what are you doing around here
okay all right I get it
I'm doing a run Oh the water monster ha
you cry-baby oh oh oh ha ha [ __ ] got
you now sucker laughs I'm the greatest
look at me I'm just too pro so so far
this guy only has a phobia of water
doesn't seem that bad for me though I
know your tricks okay I tend to jump
back down ow
huh Wow Wow okay never mind which way my
oh I get it okay
never mind sorry my bad my mistake my
mistake my MS egg boxes Magus so many
boxes okay boxes will help me the boxes
help me yeah boxes he'll be all right
which way am I supposed to go oh right
here in the spiral oh okay that was easy
I haven't filled my Lantern in this
whole time I wonder if they only gave me
enough to last me through the entire
game at the beginning I don't know if
they did that be awfully convenient but
I have a feeling I'm gonna run out
because I haven't exactly been sparing
with it
okay so is that all you got
is that all you got game come on bring
it on I got balls of steel aah
I need to find a key donor Oh key dokey
I can find it I know your tricks I know
how you work now you hide it either in
plain sight or really well it's one of
the two you can move either these No
so it's gotta be down aha oh well this
isn't exactly very well but whatever
okay I thought somebody might have
popped up bhai oh okay oh okay that's
how it's gonna be huh
that's how it's gonna be so what did I
get this crowbar for oh that's gonna
break okay we're good never mind wasn't
gonna break all right uh try a crowbar
but it's rusted and break what I want I
didn't even try it okay thanks thanks
for taking that crowbar No
Oh doh where am i go where do I go oh oh
I was the wrong way yeah that's awfully
convenient I don't have any body parts
to give him oh oh oh here's a body part
ah
yeah oh I don't think it's gone for it
maybe it is is it oh it is okay it's
good good it's good it's good
okay we're good huh dick dick bag dick
bag Oh what you man I could have gone
here why didn't I just go here in the
first place
oh oh I get it oh I get it I get it
all right I see I see what you're doing
okay all right there we go
got it so that was a good move you did
good I guess who's this am I looking at
here oh okay I get it
oh oh oh oh oh we're gonna do what are
you gonna do who's that
so the key no it's broken you gonna do
something I know you are I know you are
I know you are I know you are okay maybe
not
or not nothing's good reign reigns now
what I was expecting
oh no okay what what happened oh hello
baby I'm very sorry for any stress
caused to you we thought that his fears
wouldn't affect you but it seems we were
wrong oh you'll never be wrong baby take
this piece and I'll get us out of here
Miele well thank you baby
you so nice but then the other part is
sorrow do I have time for sorrow I think
I have time for sorrow that was
horrifying at least it's out of the way
of nightmares about that forever five
ever okay sorrow let's do it
I'm guessing it's gonna be dead baby
sorrow you're doing well only a little
way to go I don't feel right the doctor
says that's normal just try to relax
well it's gonna be sad I think one more
push will do it ah it's out it's a
healthy little boy honey look at our
look honey
Anna Oh Oh
get the crash Kurt this isn't the kind
of sad that I was expecting her BP is
dropping clear no response what's wrong
with her Oh sad oh no that's horrible
I mean I'm not I'm not like expecting
like oh I worked that baby no not baby
Dennison but every day that I've come
here it's been raining funny thing is
that doesn't scare me as much as being
alone I miss you so much
oh that's so sad the poor guy
I'm sorry I didn't know that poor guy he
couldn't get another date to save his
life and then the lovers life died what
happened to the kid though that's what I
wondered what happened to their child
they say the mind bends and twists to
deal with the horrors of life I think
mine bent so much it snapped in two I'd
say the worst of it is over I'm not sure
the demons are becoming agitated no area
of your mind may be safe now well that's
just ducky I guess I should hurt that's
just ducky what does that mean
okay all right then so apparently we're
just gonna have straight-up fear for the
rest of it that's selfishness and
knowledge while knowledge can't be too
bad I guess but either way I'm all out
of time for this part here I'm kind of
not but at the same time I'm like I
don't want to go over cuz I like to have
I don't know either way I'd like to keep
it all in candidated what with when you
know what I mean all right so thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will say
in the next video by
why would you offer me a benefit
but what do we know
in the building
all of you wear